people can swim and dive in such a right
through until autumn the city on
Russia's Black Sea coast has a
subtropical climate Victor ponomaryov
owns a diving school in the city he
hopes more foreign tourists will come
soon events like the winter olympics and
the upcoming Formula One Grand Prix are
good adverts for the city he says
massive ellenwood we expected more of
this season it did not go as well as we
had hoped but people are starting to
come business is picking up service is
improving and that will attract more
tourists look what the fascia
many here in Sochi are counting on
sports like diving and the tourist
industry they're hoping to build on the
success of the winter olympics the track
for the Grand Prix runs between two
winter sports stadiums the competition
is due to be held here every year until
2020 but on the edge of the city
thousands of apartments and conference
rooms stand empty deputy mayor sergei
yushchenko says these are just teething
problems he's confident so she will
attract more competitions as well as
tourists and investors maybe this Lola
and good at the at the there is no doubt
that this city is the first place in
Russia where we have proven that we are
capable of competing on the
international tourism market distrito
luigina mizner owner in liquidity square
business many residents hope the Winter
Olympics would improve their lives and
lead to gas and running water in every
home including in the mountains but
Valerie Karpov is still waiting instead
the construction work for the Olympics
caused the local well to dry up a truck
is now supposed to deliver fresh water
every week but the last time it came was
20 days ago dr. animo quite the post
Madrid I couldn't even go and see what
was happening at the games the tickets
were too expensive in many countries
where the games take place again people
who live there get tickets for free I
would be so what about here when I
certainly wasn't able to afford any
tickets the only good thing he says is
that the construction work is finally
over he doesn't care whether so she
becomes a magnet for sports tourists or
not for him and many other residents
here nothing has changed